and with the last stance on everybody's
mind on everybody's lips everybody's
wondering what we saw and what else was
there and let's get him on Rashad on
because I don't recall anybody who
covering an athlete and an era and
having a catbird seat position quite
like he had on all those years on the
NBA on NBC and he's kind of off to call
in the Rich Eisen show how you been
Ahmad how are you I'm better for talking
to you I'm better for talking tired the
introduction and I was like NBC former
something you know I played football
well Ahmad right on our screen right
here it's not underneath former NBC
Sports commentator it says four-time Pro
Bowl wide receiver with Vikings you know
I know you know when you get oh you need
that stuff should we have a last dance
on the Vikings on your Viking some-odd
would that look like things where my
daughter at one point came home from
school and said hey there's a kid at
school that wants your autograph he said
you played for the Vikings did you come
on okay maybe I tried too hard to make
people forget did your did your did your
daughter not know you were fourth
overall pick of in the National Football
League Draft no no clue if she's
listening now it's probably the first
time you've heard that no is this the
same daughter who's killing it on
billions right now Ahmad she's dynamite
man she is dynamo thank you in that show
just dynamite and I guess it's a good
segue do you think Jordan would have
respected you in the manner that he did
if you weren't a former athlete coming
to him
Ahmad no I don't think so and you know
what rich I think that a lot of the guys
would have felt the same way it's
because NBC had not been doing
basketball then all of a sudden we got
the franchise to do basketball and the
guy that they sort of put in from NBC to
put in place at the NBA was me mm-hmm
you know so we were you know we were
trying to do things to show that we were
knowledgeable about basketball by by
doing Matt
Johnson's mid number something Midsummer
Night's Dream we did that justice order
and introduced iced up to those guys but
I always felt like I got the same sort
of reception from all the players so one
was the first time you met Jordan what
was the first time you met him shook his
hand covered him or something like that
the first time I met him was at that
midnight Midsummer Night's Dream game
out there in LA mm-hmm and we just had
they're all you know that was it that
was the time where guys would play in
these all-star games during the summer
and it was a real game you know it
wasn't like they were out there like
Globetrotters or something they actually
really were playing with egos involved
so that was the first time I had met him
in and we just sort of met after the
game talked and exchanged phone numbers
and so the rest in terms of how our
relationship develops it developed from
that well I mean if there's one thing
that it anybody learned from this
documentary is that anything that Jordan
ever played in wasn't just a regular
game right I mean there was a real you
know that's one thing in that that I'm
sure if anybody needed to be introduced
to Jordan and there's a whole there's
all a whole generation that did they
just learned that and I've asked this
question of every single person we've
had on this show that either appeared in
the last dance or has working knowledge
or having covered or or is friendly with
anybody on the team I asked this
question of you two did you learn
anything from the last dance Ahmad
Rashad no I didn't I didn't because I
think you know like you said when you
introduced me I had a catbird seat to
all of it
and it was one of those different sort
of I've never sort of been in a
situation where I had sort of free
access to the locker room you know to
the training room to their buses to I
was just there so I got a chance to see
a lot of those things but you know as a
former athlete I sort of knew about a
lot of them too and this was just a
little bit closer because there wasn't
that many people but no I didn't I
didn't see anything that surprised me I
was glad that people got a chance to see
the human side of Michael and you see
how much how competitive he was and how
demanding he was and I think what I what
I take from that is if you think Larry
Bird wasn't like that and if you think
Magic Johnson wasn't like that then
you're not really thinking the right way
just Michel that was just you know when
it all costs put your foot on the guys
neck kind of thing all these guys were
able to do that but Michael which
separated him was his athletic ability
was way above anybody's at that point so
that's you know what you saw but that
hard driving leadership thing I think
magic had done I think Larry Bird had
that night you know there's a lot of
guys you can sort of go through the
league and that had that same sort of
luck for winning well we had Shaq on
yesterday Ahmad and the sweetheart that
Shaq is and I enjoyed seeing on Twitter
this past week of him breaking a
backboard on the inside stuff with you
was great singing that from back in that
day nice little stroll time everybody in
there we had the sweetheart Shack on
yesterday and I asked him about the
subject of Jordans demeanor and and and
his hard-driving that some of his
teammates would grind his gears and he
was insulted he's like you don't think I
was that way I mean that's he there's
exactly what he said when I brought that
up with ya and it and it is and it's in
all sports when you see guys that you
know you see Tom Brady whose smiles and
looks like such a nice guy I guarantee
you he is riding them dudes to death
when a weekly a weekly basis that's just
the way that is so now a mob Rashad here
on the Rich Eisen show oh what's the
scoop with the pizza were you in that
room when the pizza arrived that night
come on not in the room I was on the
phone and I knew the pizza had come over
I knew his eating pizza and then I knew
a few hours later that he had gotten
sick okay so I knew all that you're on
the phone when the pizza arrived in the
room yes yeah I you know they were
getting ready to eat they were just kind
of messing around doing what they're
doing and they were just getting ready
to eat and the pizza came and we got off
the phone and that was it then I found
out about four hours there that he was
sick as a dog he called you to basically
say I'm sick he called you well no it
wasn't him call me it was there's George
Kohler I spoke to George Courtland right
and George was in the room
see now did you know at the time that it
was pizza ever why did we wait why did
it take 20 years for much of the free
world to learn this was a stomach bug or
a food poisoning situation I don't know
I don't know you know every time I used
to say this
you know I'd read something to say was
the flu game and I say he didn't have
the flu he had food poisoning you know I
I just and I never paid any more
attention to it than that but I remember
such isn't that game always referred to
as the flu game yes oh yes yeah I don't
I don't remember no flu I do remember
that in the other flu and how is he
playing the piano and doing all that
stuff after the game so I don't think
that was it at all so I mean you know as
always with Jordan there's always some
sort of you know one would say a
conspiracy theory that he was actually
out at night and that he was doing
something that he shouldn't have been
doing as opposed to eating the pizza but
that did what did you report the next
day I report that he had gotten sick he
had eaten the pizza and it got really
really sick and he was throwing up and
all that kind of stuff and the funny
thing about it is once he started to
play because he kept saying I'm gonna
play so I said yeah he's going to play
and I remember them always coming down
to me as it's either a poison give us a
report on Jordan so I say you know he's
sick he's thinking at food poisoning and
about five minutes later said give us
another report I'd say he steals it
another report yep he's still sick it
was one of the things what else can I
say
Ahmad what can I say right thanks well
now I mean it's just what you want to
talk about a unique situation I mean you
you got access to easily the most famous
person on the planet most famous athlete
of his time still one of the most famous
people on the planet you had all that
and then I'm sure there was things going
on that you couldn't report on and what
was that balancing act for you Ahmad I
never you know the things that I was
going to report on had to do with
basketball so I never thought that I was
holding secrets or anything like that I
mean my job was to report on the game
report on things that were happening
that way I never even thought about
there was no investigative reporting
going on and there was no reason for
that the other part was just friends we
were just friends and it wasn't like you
sneaking around so what was that who you
talk to did it none of that ever went on
and I think that you know because of his
stature and the mystique around him
that there were so many theories I think
you mentioned as there were so many
theories that we would laugh at you know
just crazy stuff but you know I guess
they could say whatever they wanted to
but it certainly was not my job to
report that the only other person I even
report on it no I know the only other
person that I would know that I had a
great access and and was became friends
with Michael was Stuart Scott do you
have any good stories about Stuart being
around or anything like that man you
know I do what a wonderful man he just
was a lot of fun he was a lot of fun he
was always up he always had like funny
things to play and it was like he was
just one of the guys you know he's one
of the guys that do it was caught he'd
be able to call and ask whatever you
needed to ask or whatever it was so it
was a very good relationship between
Stuart and Michael also ya know but my
church it was also Stuart was also
reporting things on you know his angle
was different than mine you know he was
doing sports news and doing things like
that I was just recording on a game
right and then how real is the Isiah
stuff Ahmad was is that reason why I
think that he was very upset when Isaiah
walked off the court here's a and let me
let me just move on and tell you what
happened with Karl Malone okay when Karl
Malone lost that final game I remember I
just can come out of the locker room and
I walked over to the bus to the Bulls
bus Karl Malone was walking up the bus
congratulating everybody on that bus on
the Bulls team just one of the greatest
acts of sportmanship sportsmanship that
I've ever seen and and nobody ever said
anything about it that was Karl doing it
from his heart and you know you got to
realize that was the second time he had
been beaten by him but I remember
watching him walk up on that bus and
going through the bus just you know
telling everybody congratulations great
game all that kinds of stuff that was a
pretty cool that was a pretty cool
moment yeah I we saw that reported yeah
we saw the video of that on the last
dance I saw that maybe Karl just knew
what happened Isaiah and he better shake
Michaels hand he didn't do it on the
court
went to go find him do you know what
happens you don't want to be you don't
to be out you want to be out forever
don't worry about stuff like you know
with with Isaiah because they had such a
rivalry with Detroit and the fact that
you know they got to the point where
they had those Jordan rules and all
those kinds of things I think that sort
of built up a little bit bit of pressure
between them but as it stands now I
don't think Michael cares much about
that I mean you know he says that Isiah
was the second best point guard to ever
play in the league tremendous respect
for the guy but you know if you don't
have to be you know Bosom Buddies but he
certainly respects them 100% I got to
tell you I want to see one more episode
of the Last Dance Ahmad and the lamb but
here's what I want to see I want to see
only the moments where the director
Jason hare handed Michael an iPad for
him to see what has been said about him
and his reactions to it that's all I
wanted all episode and also maybe a
camera or maybe a camera on every single
person that knew they said something
about Michael in their house watching
Michael get handed this iPad nervous
that they're about to see them that's
what I want the last episode doing so
that so maybe you did learn something
maybe you did learn something from it
that he well I already knew what he did
but I was like no you just really said
that huh okay I think it's I think it's
one of those things where you know
Michael's always said you know I've had
this tape for a bunch of years we're
gonna let it out and that's it I'm not
gonna do any interviews about it I'm not
gonna talk about it he's tired of seeing
it now you know it's like one of those
things where here you guys look and you
make up your mind and that's it I don't
I'm not gonna stand up and explain any
of it that's just it well I think that's
pretty that's pretty cool well that's
two of them one of the last two
questions I want to ask you am
is why why do you think he finally
decided to say okay let's do this why do
you think he gave this a green light I
think part of it was a you know he's
hard as he drove his team mates he loved
each and one of each and every one of
those guys and it was one of those it
was a story that needed to be told and
the only person that could tell it was
him so he was the one sitting on it
takes yeah if he wouldn't have said you
can release him way to never saw it so I
think it became time he became far
enough away from it that it was like
okay here let's take a look at it and
that's it because I think he enjoyed
watching it watching it also and and but
I know that he's not gonna answer any
questions we watch it together and laugh
I mean there's so many you know you know
how you do when you watch something you
saw at this point you start pointing out
different things and just laughing you
know just laughing and it's been a lot
of fun you know like a high school
reunion kinda again
so did you are you saying you watched it
together with him or or you'd call
Sunday nights we sit and watch it and
we'd laugh at the stuff and remember the
stuff and remember different players
like hey remember that guy that dude was
tough he could really go to his left
well remember that guy he did this than
the other whatever that guy you know
stuff like that
so it's just all in fun it's not anyway
anything more than that so that's a
little bit of tequila
little bit of tequila as you're watching
it have a good time okay but nobody
ordered a pizza though right come on
nobody order pizza there'll be no more
no one will be delivering pizzas okay
yeah just making it yourself okay so
then I guess the last how about that
okay so you were I guess Jordan
sheltered in place and you go over or
something like that is that how you
would watch so we've all been sheltered
okay we've been on this you know we've
been sheltered for the longest time so
right now that's one of our that's been
one of our Sunday night thing is to go
watch a thing that's me okay
yeah I I watch it with my wife you watch
it with Jordan that's that's the way
you're rolling okay last question for
you a mob here yeah you bet you're
having a better time okay
last one for you last one did Jordan
ever have a meeting with Phil after the
final season to say are we done here in
the same way that Reinsdorf said to
Michael after he retired the first time
this is not official and not public
until you have a conversation with Phil
please and then they did and then they
you know obviously Phil accepted it and
and Michael went and played baseball so
did these two guys ever have a
conversation best to your knowledge to
try and keep this band together in the
manner that Jordan said he would have
been willing to do no I don't think that
ever happened why I don't think they had
to meet I think it was over and and and
as a fan if you switch on the family
that's a shame that's a shame that they
weren't able to play until they lost
CIHI but it just was I think the
situation had so much pressure on it at
the end you know to have the so-called
new coach be around the team you know
and have the general manager test saying
that no matter what you do this is your
last year it's kind of hard to get past
that you know what I mean it's kind of
it's hard to work under those
circumstances I give Phil Jackson so
much credit for keeping that team
together with all those crazy people
they had on that team you know mainly
Dennis and all the other people to keep
all these guys together and have them
rally to win a championship is one of
the greatest things that I've ever seen
a coach do ever because I knew the
Claire's and I knew the coach and I know
it wasn't just anybody when you talk
about a great coach it's usually a great
manager of men and Bill Jackson did that
better than anyone anyone I'm it the
example at the in Utah when when when
Rodman went to a wrestling match and
Miss packed practice any other coach
would have probably suspended him you
know or an indium IRA would have lost
the game but but at least bill was able
to make it make the team understand that
dinner said let him down you know you
really let us down we were really trying
to rally here but we're not going to do
anything about you let us down you'll
feel bad about and you realize the next
night he went out and got 20 rebounds
you know so he was a great great
motivator and Michael says that one of
the most important things in his whole
career is that he had a coach that
challenged him every single day
challenged him to be better challenging
them to be better I think that's pretty
cool
I think that's um you know that's a
that's a legendary stuff no doubt that's
inside stuff hey now how about that's
the inside stuff from Ahmad Rashad hey I
have one question for you okay what do
you got what was your time what was your
time in the 40 thanks for asking Ahmad
uh it was five nine six this year five
nine six this year right always a 599 I
might have just beaten it I don't know
but it was sub six I'm a fine wine sort
of like that stuff that Jordan was
drinking on the Last Dance this trinket
is he's drinking his tequila right is
that what he's doing in that oh yeah
yeah what was your 40 time come on
what was your 40 time I ran for four
damn straight you did of course that's
why Bud Grant was all over you right it
was a good time it's been a great life
I've enjoyed every element every every
everyday all of it's all been good
absolutely Hey Ahmad maybe we'll have
you on in a couple weeks
let's talk football how about that
nothing but football I'd love it too
thanks to the calamari appreciate you
can job look I'll reach out and and and
you take care of yourself be happy and
be safe okay you do the same thing you
got it that's a mod Rashad right here on
the Rich Eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here